so this the Santa story and what
happened related to Flying 50 people to
Martha's Vineyard which DeSantis said he
was going to do he got the money in his
budget the Democrats in the state senate
voted for it okay now they're all
calling him racist on the very same
thing that they voted for uh it's
exposing hypocrisy at the most
extraordinary levels as I said on Friday
this is like one of the best red pill
moments it's such a great story because
it's showing how inept all of these
people are so here is our black lesbian
press secretary Karin Jean-Pierre
getting called out at the White House
for doing the same thing that the
Sanders did this is apparently
um you know he said it was essentially
no different than what the federal
government has done in uh sending you
know flights in the middle of the night
that's where it's characterized it uh
you know taking migrants to various
different states a few of our response
to them
so we are offering Solutions that's what
the Biden Harris Administration has been
doing since day one including on the
first day putting forth a comprehensive
immigration reform to deal with this
issue God she's incredible like it's not
I don't know what questions she's
answering it doesn't matter she just has
a we offering Solutions it's sort of
like Kamala remember the video we showed
you last week is the border secure every
nation has a border they just answer
questions that have nothing to do with
nothing they say words to get to the
period in the sentence so the sentence
is over and they've done nothing but
take you on a ride of BS so of course
what they're referring to there is that
the federal government we know this has
put migrants on planes when they cross
over the border and then sent them all
over the country we know so the Santa
said hey I'm just doing the same thing
that they've been doing and she has no
response to that of course and then you
get all these clowns that are trying to
figure out a way to just to sue DeSantis
and everything else but again if you
just look at the reality whether whether
you think it's a political Ploy whether
you don't like own of any of this or if
you think it's just mutually assured
destruction
what what is next to all of that is one
guy did exactly what he said he was
going to do and then one guy Biden
didn't do what he said he was going to
do because they say that there's a
border but now these people are pouring
in so there obviously isn't a safe
border and then you have these crazy
Democrats with their idea of sanctuary
cities and Martha's Vineyard they had a
big thing at Town Hall about nobody's
illegal and everything else and then
when 50 people showed up they get 150
National Guard and they boot them in 24
hours it's rather extraordinary